[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم وقف اطلاق نار في
بين في الحرب الدائره بين اسرائيل رائع
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي في غزه وقف اطلاق
النار الذي تم التوصل اليه امس يطرح
مجموعه كبيره من الاسئله تتعلق باهداف
اسرائيل من هذه الحرب على غزه وتحديدا
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي ولماذا الجهاد
الاسلامي موقف حماس موقف ايران طبيعه
الوساطه المصريه على ماذا توافقوا
سيناريوهات تطور هذه العمليه كل الاسئله
دي حبيت اطرحها على السفير رفعت الانصاري
طبعا التقطوه تعرفوه واظلكم ان شاء الله
سوف تعرفونه اكثر من خلال قناته اللي
هكلمكم عنها واللي هيخصصها للشان
الاسرائيلي
وهنتطرق اليها اثناء الحوار لكن احنا
النهارده بنحاول نفهم منه ماذا يجري على
الارض وماذا قد نشهده خلال الايام المقبله
من خلال قراءته للمخططات الاسرائيليه فيما
يتعلق بقطاع غزه والضفه الغربيه مساء
الخير مع السفير مساء الخير وحشتني انت
وجمهورك وبقى لنا فتره فانا يعني
سعدت بدعوتك ليا النهارده ربنا يخليك
ويسعدك هسال حضرتك على القناه اللي انا
مهتم بها جدا واللي انت فيه يعني في مرحله
الاطلاق لها خلال ايام لكن الناس المتشوقه
جدا يعرفوا او مهتمين جدا يعرفوا ماذا
يجري الان على الارض وما هو المتوقع خلال
الايام المقبله تهدئه كامله
وايه شروطها ولا للاسف سوف يعني تتجدد
عمليه اطلاق النار بكل تكلفتها الباهظه
على الفلسطينيين تسمح لي ادي لك بس
لجمهورك الكريم اديلك خلفيه
قطاع غزه استقل من اسرائيل او انسحبت
اسرائيل منه من 2005 من 2005 لغايه
النهارده هذه هي العمليه رقم 15
وعمليات اسرائيليه داخل القطع لم تستطع
اسرائيل حسم مصر كامل في اي من ال 15
عمليه
في 12 نوفمبر 2019 وبعد توقف حوالي يمكن
خمس سنين قامت اسرائيل باغتيال شخصيه مهمه
الحقيقه هو بهاء ابو العطاء وده كان قائد
وحده الصواريخ
لدى حركه الجهاز
بعد اقل من 3 سنين فاغسطس 2022 اغتالت
شخصيتين
واحد هو تيسير الجعبري ده كان قائد الجبهه
الجنوبيه
والتاني كان خالد منصور وخالد منصور غير
انه كان قائد الجبهه الشماليه الا ان هو
من اشرف على حفر النفق من داخل في وسط
القطاع غزه وصل به الى تحت السياج الحدودي
وكانت اسرائيل بتحاول قدر الامكان انها
تصل الى هذا النفق ما كانتش لسه وصلت له
الحقيقه اسرائيل اتخذت قرار بتصفيه جماعيه
لقيادات الحركه دهيت وهذا القرار اخدته من
رمضان اللي فات
عندما بدات حركه الجهاد كمقاومه بدات في
قصف اسرائيل بصواريخ ردا على احداث المسجد
الاقصى لحدثت في رمضان
الضرب باهداف العمليه كامله الا ان هذه
العمليه الحقيقه يعني كانت مفاجاه ومفاجاه
للجانب الفلسطيني ايضا لاملاح حركات
المقاومه لانهم توقعوا انه اسرائيل عدت
هذا الموضوع في رمضان وبالتالي
سينتهي لما جه خضر عدنان القيادي خضر
عدنان توفى في داخل السجون فبدات الحركه
ايضا تطلق صواريخ لان هم طلبوا بجسمانه
واسرائيل رفضت
يوم التلات تسع مايو بدات اسرائيل قبل
العمليه بحوالي ساعتين وفي نطاق حوالي 40
كم من خارج غزه بدات في كذا اجراء الحقيقه
مهمين
نمره واحد
اوقفت القطارات اللي ماشيه في ذلك المكان
اوقفت الدراسه في المدارس فتحت الملاجئ في
مدينه عسقلان
غيرت مسار الطيران ولا نازل على مطار كل
دوت تحسبا ليه اي رشقات من المقاومه من
حركه الجهاز
بعدها على طول وبعد توقف يعني ده من تسعه
اشهر من اغسطس اللي فات بدات عمليه الدرع
والسهم زي ما بيقولوا عليه وكان الهدف
اساسا بدايه هو اغتيال القيادات
حركه الجهاد حركه الجهاد وفي اول عشر
دقايق من يوم التلات تسعه مايو صباحا
تم اغتيال ثلاث قيادات هم جهاد الغنام وده
من قيادات الصف الاول وده مسئول عن تجنيد
خلايا تتبع حركه الجهاد داخل الضفه
الغربيه في اسرائيل دخلت الضفه الغربيه
داخل الارض المحتله
الثاني كان خليل البهتيني وده المسؤول عن
وحده الصواريخ اللي هي بتاعه حركه الجهاد
وده اللي كان كمان يعني بيشرف بنفسه على
ضرب الصواريخ مش بس في رمضان ساعه خضر
عدنان
الثالث الحقيقه كان
طارق عز الدين وده كان خرج ضمن اطار تبادل
اسرى وعاد واصبح من القياديين العسكريين
واصبح قائد عمليات
حركه الجهاد الكلام ده كان يوم التلات يوم
التلات تسعه مايو صباح الفرشه دقايق
التلاته اتضربوا في نفس التوقيت
فده يدلك على انه الحصول على المعلومات
بتاعه مساراتهم مواقعهم كانت كبيره وعلى
الرغم انه الموساد كان يعلم انهم دخلوا في
هذه البنايات السكنيه وكانوا مع عائلتهم
الا انه الطيران الاسرائيلي ضربهم هم
بعائلتهم فعشان كده لما استشهدوا استشهدوا
هم وامراتهم واولادهم للاسف الشديد
يوم الخميس تم اغتيال شخصين الحياه مهمين
علي غالي وهو رئيس وحده الصواريخ اللي حل
محل بقى ابو العطا بتاع 2019 والنائب
بتاعه النائب بتاعه كان اسمه اياد الحساني
اذا العمليه اصبحت واضحه فيما يتعلق بدقه
تحديد المواقع والمسارات
الطيران بقى قام بتنفيذ ضربات الاغتيال
بقصد ثم توصلوا الى النفق ايضا من خلال
معلومات التلات اجهزه فتم قصف النفق اللي
هو كان معمول بقى له ثلاث سنين
اسرائيل عملت حوالي 371 غاره جويه
الى امس الى امس اللي هو قبل 13
الكلام ده اصفر عن 33 شهيد منهم سته
قيادات صف اول و12 قياده صف ثاني وثالث
وبالباقي بقى اطفال ونساء وخلافه
تم ضرب 215 موقع لحركه الجهات للمقاومه
215 موقع عباره عن مراكز اتصال مراكز
قياده
مخازن سلاح ورش عمل صواريخ وهكذا
وتم قصف 15 بنايه سكنيه
الخسائر كانت عاليه الحقيقه في مقابل كده
الحركه اطلقت يعني نقدر نقول ايه 1250
1300 تقريبا قذيفه وصاروخ وده بيمثل 15%
من مخزونها اللي هي واخداها من ايران
بالكامل يعني
في حوالي 900 تخطم حاجز قطاع غزه في 250
300 وقعوا في غزه وعملوا خساير في
الفلسطينيين في الفلسطينيين في اربعه
شهداء من الفلسطينيين من هذه اللي بيقولوا
عليها النيران صديقه
وال800 وشويه دول حوالي يمكن 700 كانوا
داخلين على مناطق ماهوله بالسكان وال 150
وقعوا في مناطق لان ما عندهمش التوجيه
والتصوير الدقيق ناحيه الاهداف
وال ال 600 وشويه اللي دخلوا دول اسرائيل
قامت بعمل الاتي منظومه جديده من
الدفاع الجوي
هذه المنظومه اسقطت 95% من الصواريخ اللي
داخله
كيف اسقطت بقى المنظومه 95% اسرائيل كان
لديها القبه الحديديه وهذه
الصواريخ قصيره المدى
ومعاها درونز بالمناسبه وكان عندها
اللي هو السهم تلاته وانه
والسهم 3 دوت كان له الصواريخ الطويله
المدى كان عنده ثغره في المتوسطه المدى
في خلال السنتين اللي فاتوا عرف بالفعل
يطور منظومه جديده اسمها
مقلاع داود
زي ايام زمان يعني بالجانب الديني عندهم
دايما في الاسامي
النقلاء داود قدرت تغطي
الصواريخ متوسطه المدى ولكن لم تكن قد
جربت من قبل فتم ضمها الى المنظومتين
قصيره وطويله المدى وبدات تعمل
بمنظومه واحده متكامله
فنجحت المدى قصيره المدى متوسطه وطويله
فنجحت اسرائيل بالفعل في ذلك ونسبه 95%
هذه نسبه كبيره وفي نفس الوقت
في صاروخ من ضمن الصواريخ ده اللي سقط
اعتقد في عسقلان وده هدم لا سوري قربه تل
ابيب وده هدم البيت ونتج عنه سيده واحده
قتلت اسرائيل اسرائيليه وخمسه جرحى جروح
خفيفه ففي مقابل 33 قتيل منهم
126 والباقي اطفال في واحده قتلت في مقابل
كان في حوالي 116 جريح ما قصادهم خمسه جرى
هذه هي النتيجه لكن يعني اما نيجي نقول
ايه
هل خططت المؤسسه العسكريه لعمليه ضرب
القطاع او ضرب المقاومه في صوره حركه
الجهاد نعم خططت
ان هي كانت بتنتظر اي فرصه
اختارت الموعد لم تكن تنتظر فرصه هي بدات
في الاعداد لها عندما كانت مكتمله الاعداد
وعندما حصلت على الضوء الاخضر من من
الاداره الامريكيه هي اختارت الموعد وعملت
الضرب طيب انا يعني حضرتك اشرت للسبب ان
هي كانت من البدايه هدف هذه العمليه هو
يعني ضرب حركه الجهاد صياد قيادات حركه
الجهاد بالمقام الاول
هنخش في اهداف العمليه ايه بعد كده بس قبل
ما اسال حضرتك عن اهداف العمليه معنى ذلك
ان الهدف الاساسي هو ضرب جماعه الجهاد
بالاضافه الى اهداف اخرى السؤال
حركه الجهاد السؤال هو لماذا حركه الجهاد
لمجرد ان هي يعني كانت فعاله في الشهور
الاخيره باطلاق صواريخ على اسرائيل اثناء
الاحداث القدس مثلا في رمضان الماضي
واطلاق صواريخ
هو ده سبب عشان بتاخدها عبره لمن لم يعتبر
ولكن النقطه المهمه هنا الحقيقه ان انا
عندي معلومات النهارده
بتقول حاجه ليست مؤكده ولكن تتواتر وايها
قادمه من من اسرائيل
لديهم ما يسمى بنك الاهداف احنا عندنا بنك
المعلومات
بنكذب وبنك الاراضي وبنك الاستثمار وخلافه
هم عندهم بنك الاهداف بنك الاهداف ده هو
فيه اسماء القيادات المستهدفه والمطلوب
تصفيتها
وبيتحطوا باولويات اهم الاولويات بتبقى
ايه وعلى فكره يعني لو تحب يعرف جمهورك
معلومه
في مقر المساد في الدور الثاني في غرفه
العمليات يوجد شاشه كبيره جدا بعرض حائط
مثلا 20 متر
وكل شغال بالكمبيوترز والكلام ده شوف من
ساعه مثلا لو اقول لك من 30 سنه كان لسه
الكمبيوتر لسه على قدها يعني انما تيجي
تقول مثلا تدخل اسم ياسر عرفات الله يرحمه
الله يرحمه فيطلع لك ياسر عرفات له رمز
ولون
عرفات يطلع باللون الاحمر هو النهارده فين
ده النهارده في الاردن هو من ثلاث ايام
كان فين كان في تونس ساب المقر المنظمه في
تونس وطلع الاردن هو مين اللي معاه في
اربع شخصيات مع
ليه هم كانوا بيفكروا مثلا انه لو
القيادات ديت فيها 12 قياده لقوا منهم
ثمانيه تواجده في باريس يبقى في حاجه
سجنيه يبقى معنى كده دول رايحين يشرفوا
على عمليه ضد المصالح الاسرائيليه فكان
بيهمهم مثل هذا تتبع المسارات وده بيتم
طبعا بمعلومات بتحدث مش يومين كل ساعه
بنك الاهداف دهوت
وربما يعني ده هيحصل على جزء كبير من او
حيكون متواجد كان قاسم مشتركه في في
الحلقات اللي انا ناوي انزلها عن اسرائيل
بنك الاهداف اضيفت له مؤخرا اربع اسماء
الاسم الاول هو حسن نصر الله رئيس حزب حزب
الله وكانوا من قبل ذلك
كانوا شالوا المبدا بتاع اغتيال قيادات
المنظمات ولو عاوز تعرف هو زمان كانت
المنظمات بتقوم على شخص القياده يعني مثلا
ايلول الاسود كانت في بدايه السبعينات
بيختار شخص القياده لو عرف يغتاله بتنهار
المنظمه لانها مركزيه منظمه جبريل كان حتى
بيطلقوا عليها منظمه جبريل بالرغم انها
اسمها منظمه الشعبيه الفلسطينيه مجرد ما
اصطاد جبريل قتلوا حصل المنظمه تفككت
فكان هذا هو الهدف من قتل او الاستهداف
لتصفيه زعماء او رؤساء هذه المنظمات
الموضوع المنظمات يعني
المقاومه وتحدثت كما منظمات مقاومه
وحركات مقاومه واصبح في البديل والبديل
الثاني والثالث واصبح هناك قيادات الصف
الاول والثاني وليس قياده واحده فلا اقم
انه اغتيال او تصفيه
القيادات بيجلب عليهم وجع دماغ في سياسي
ويعني اعتراض عارم من كافه الدول ان شخصيه
اعلاميه معروفه فهو ابتدا بعد كده يبدا في
تصفيه القيادات التي لها
الميدانيه واهم حاجه النسبه القيادات حركه
الجهاد مثلا
انها
هذه القيادات من منهم سيسبب حالات قتل
للجنود اسرائيليين في ارض المعركه
هيبقوا بتوع وحده الصواريخ فعشان كده هو
بيصطاد بتوع وحده الصواريخ ده واللي بعده
يعني ده انا حتى
الثالث انا نسيت يمكن اقوله اسمه يد
الحساني اياد الحساني دهوت ده كان اصلا
يعني في مجلس الحركه
وكان مسؤول عن بعض التنظيمات ولكن لسه كان
بيحل محل البهتيني ما بقالوش 48 ساعه ده
بقى يوم الجمعه الله يرحمه
حضرتك قلت عشان النقطه اللي انت قلت نقطه
مهمه بس الاول المهم وفقا لمعلومات حضرتك
وطبعا انت عندك مصادرك الخاصه
ووفقا لمصادرك الخاصه
بتتواتر
تمام انا بقولها يعني
صناع القرار في اسرائيل ادرجوا اربع
شخصيات قياديه على بنك اهدافهم للاغتيال
المختفيه للتصفيه وان هذا الاربع الاسامي
الاول حسن نصر الشيخ حسن نصر الله الثاني
زياد نخاله وده نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس
الثالث قالوا ليحيى السنوار وده كان فعلا
يعني دي طالعه بتهديد من اسرائيل دي كانت
معلنه يحيى السنوار قائد الحركه في القطع
سنستهدفك اذا ما تحركت حماسه دخلت على
الخط في هذا الموضوع والرابع اسمه صلاح
العروري انا ما اعرفوش الحقيقه ولكن هو
جهاد احد قياد اعتقد الجهاد تعظيمه اعتقد
يا ريت من المتابعيننا من الفلسطينيين
يكتبوا لنا يعني طبيعه نشاط هذه الشخصيه
القياده عظيم جدا فانت حضرتك بتقول امه
مهمه قوي كنت اتمنى ان احنا نتوقف عندها
كتير بس لو توقفنا عندها هنخرج بره
المساله شويه ودي محتاجه حلقه يعني محتاجه
حلقه هتبقى على قناه حضرتك اكيد ان شاء
الله عظيم جدا ان شاء الله بس سؤالي انا
انه
وفقا لمعلوماتك لما يدرجه لما يكون في هذا
التطور الدرامي بادراك شخصيات بحجم حسن
نصر الله ويحيى السنوار والقيادات الاخرى
الهامه جدا اللي اشرت اليها
لما يدرجوها على بنك اهدافهم ده ايه ده
تطور خطير لازم اكيد ليه اسبابه الثقه
بالغه بان هم قادرين على احتواء رد فعل
مثلا حزب الله على احتواء حركه حماس هل في
تقدير الشخصي انه لما يضعوا على بنك
الاهداف اولا علشان يغتال يقوم بتصفيه شخص
ما لها اجراءات قانونيه
خطوات هناك
بالنسبه لهم
ويعرض الاسم على رئيس الوزاره ورئيس
الوزاره بيكون لجنه واللجنه ديت بيبقى
فيها اللجنه دي بيبقى فيها محامي للشخص
اللي هيتم تصفيته والمحامي ده بيحاول
يدافع عنه داخل
لقصه يعني عندي حلقه كامله عليها داخل
محكمه
غير معروفه لدى القضاء والمحكمه ديت بيتم
وبتخش في اجراءات الى ان تتخذ المحكمه
قرار بانه
دايما القرار بيبقى كالاتي لو استطاعت
القوات الاسرائيليه ان ان تختطف هذه
الشخصيه وتجيبها للمحاكمه الافضل يبقى
افضل لكن ان لم تستطع فاذا القرار هو خاص
بالتصفيه فتوافق الجانب القانوني بالنسبه
لهم فيرفع الى رئيس الوزاره فرئيس الوزاره
يقر فتصبح هدف مشروع بالنسبه مشروع
بالنسبه له محطوط في القائمه الاداه لا
يحتاج الى
موافقه مره اخرى الا انه بس بيبلغ رئيس
الوزراء بانه سيتم الاغتيال الهدف رقم 2
من على قائمتنا ان احنا وصلنا له فبيقول
جعد او استنوا شويه طبقا للوضع السياسي
معلومه مهمه حضرتك قلت لي معلومات مهمه
جدا بس انا كان سؤالي انه وفقا للمعلومات
لو صدقت هذه المعلومه بوضع هذه الاسماء
الثقيله على بنك الاهداف انت طورت الاحداث
افهم من كده ان هم كانوا بيستعدوا الى
تصعيد كبير لا انا لسه يمكن ما كملتش في
تقدير الشخص انه الان هذه الاهداف ستكون
خامله متوقفه
بمجرد لو حصلت مواجهه مع حزب الله يعني
كمثل
سيكون عندهم اوردي الحافز
والموافقه على محاوله اغتيال التصفيات
الشيخ حسن نصر بالنسبه مع حماس يبقى
للسنوار
سيكون عندهم المخطط لاجراء عمليه انتحاريه
لان ده هيكون رد فعله عنيف جدا من ضعيف
جدا من حزب الله لكن دي قصه ممكن نتكلم
عنها في وقت لاحق وانت حضرتك بتقول في كل
الاحوال
دقيق بتقول هذه معلومات تاتيك من مصادر لم
تؤكد لك مدى دقتها تتواتر وان لم نكن لم
تكن مؤكده ولكن ما هو مؤكد نتنياهو اعلى
انه السنوار في حاله تدخل سيكون هدفا
مستهدفا لنا في داخل القطار
ملفت للنظر ليه على كل الاحوال حضرتك
بتقول نرجع للعمليه انت حضرتك احنا قلنا
يعني تفاصيل كيف بدات العمليه
العمليه كان مخطط لها منذ احداث القدس او
من رمضان الماضي وان هم ارادوا يعني
استغلال الفرصه بعد ان حصلوا على ضوء اخضر
من الولايات المتحده هسال حضرتك عليه لكن
واضح ان العمليه لها مجموعه اهداف تتجاوز
هذا الهدف المهم وهذا تصفيه قيادات حركه
الجهاد لو حابب حبيت اطلب من حضرتك تلخص
لي اهم اهداف هذه العمليه التي جرت منذ 9
مايو والتي توصلت توصلت رفاها اسرائيل
والجهاد الى وقف اطلاق نار بواسطه مصريه
مؤقتا ايه الاهداف نبدا بالدوافع الاول
قبل الاحداث
الحقيقه نتنياهو خضع لضغوط شديده من
الحكومه المصغره الحكومه المصغره بيسيطر
عليها اليمين المتجدد تماما اذا كنا
بنتكلم انه
اهم دوافع لضغوط حضرتك بتقول
شديده الحيه وبالذات كمان بعد ما الحركه
ضربت في الاول حركه الجهاد ضربت الحركه
دائما باعتبار حركه منظمه تبقى وحركه
بتبقى حركه حماس منظمه بتبقى منظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه وهي حركات مقاومه كلها
انما
اتعرض لضغوط شديده بالذات بعد ضرب
حركه الجهاد لقصف الصواريخي اللي تم في
رمضان دون رد
الحاجه التانيه
نتنياهو فقط كثير من شعبيته واخر تلاته هو
بيجي نمره اتنين بعد استطلاعات
نتيجه الاضطرابات الداخليه واعتراضهم على
مشروع
انه في نفس الوقت انه بمجرد بدء هذه
العمليه دايما اسرائيل بتحتاج الى عشان
تتوحد تحتاج الى عدوان خارجي او تهديد
خارجيه بمعنى ادق فاذا اما يبدا مثل هذا
هذه العمليه هذا دافع انه في الداخل
سيستطيع ان
يحط حاله من التهدئه
وبالذات احنا شفنا ان المظاهره اللي كانت
طالعه يوم الجمعه اول امس تم وقفها بمعرفه
الناس اللي طالعين يتظهروا قالوا لا مش
دلوقتي مش هينفع لان احنا لسه في حاله حرب
احتجاجات ضد رئيس الحكومه اللي هو بيقود
عمليه عسكريه
وفي نفس الوقت هيبقى مدخل له ان هو بالفعل
يقصر مده وضع القانون الخاص بالاصلاح
القضائي او الهيكله القضائيه اللي هو
بيهدف اليه هيكسر مده التفاوض مع رئيس
الجمهوريه وهيحاول يدخله بقى في اثناء هذه
العمليه وبعد انتهاء فورا هيحاول يدخله في
على الكنيست للتصوير انا ده تقدير شخصي
وليس يعني لكنه احد دوافع نتنياهو اللي
موجوده في طب قبل حركه تنتقل الى الدفع
الثاني استاذن حضرتك اذكر الساده
المشاهدين اللي هم مش متابعين للشان
الاسرائيلي هو
نتنياهو بيتعرض الى اضطرابات واحتجاجات
واسعه داخل اسرائيل احتجاجا على عدد من
سياساته واهمها مشروع ما يسمي بالاصلاح
القضائي اللي هو بيعتبره كنوع من توازن
بين السلطات اللي موجوده في اسرائيل
ويفتقد وتغول النظام القضائي على السلطه
التنفيذيه وسلطه التشريعيه لكن المحتجين
وعددهم جدا بيعتقدوا ان هو بيحاول تسييس
القضاء والسيطره عليه ومحاوله استخدام هذه
الاصلاحات لمنافعه الشخصيه والتهرب من تهم
قضائيه بتلاحقه وتلاحق عدد من من اعضاء
حكومتها
رابط الحلقه اللي كنا اتكلمنا عنها في هذا
القضيه رابط الحلقه وان شاء الله في اسفل
للحلقه يعني طيب هذا هو الدافع الاول دافع
داخلي اتعلق
بالمشاكل اللي بواجهها رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيلي في نفس الوقت حب يشغل الناس
يعني مش بس كده وهو عليه ضغوط ايضا لكن
لما لما اجتمعت الحكومه بكامل
اعضائها الكلام ده كان يوم الخميس عندما
اجتمعت وجدت يعني ان هناك طيارين
التيار الاول الحقيقه كان بيقوده
المخابرات الحربيه والمخابرات الداخليه
بانهم لا يتوقفوا وانهم مع التصعيد وانهم
ليسوا مع المهدنه
وانضم ليهم نتنياهو في البدايه
وعشان كده حتى نتنياهو اصدر
تصريح الاسرائيل ستصعد من الان ولن تهادل
يوم الخميس بعد التيار الثاني كان يعني
بعضويه عدد من الوزراء السياسيين ولكن
بقياده المساد اللي هي كانت شايفه انه لا
داعي للاستمرار لانه من الممكن يعني
التهدئه عدم تصعيد
خوفا من انفتاح المشهد الامني على اسرائيل
في مواجهه تؤدي الى دخول حماس مثلا يبقى
مواجهه غير مرغوبه وغير محسوبه خوفا من
التصعيد اللي ليس له فيعني
[تصفيق]
نيجي بعد كده عشان كده يوم الخميس توقفت
المحادثات واسرائيل ابلغت مصر ان انا مش
هكمل في المحادثات الخاصه
تهدئه وقف معنى كده ان الجناح اللي هو كان
راغب في التصعيد هو اللي انتصر كان في
البدايه كده البدايه
حصل بعد كده الحقيقه نقطه مهمه ان يوم
الجمعه بيبقى فيه لجنه تنسيقيه ما بين كل
اجهزه المخابرات تقديرات اللجنه المشتركه
لاجهزه المخابرات ديت كانت يعني وصلت الى
توصيات عامه ثم حاجات يعني
محدده التوصيات العامه اساسا انه المشهد
اصبح معقد وعلى الرغم من ان اسرائيل لها
حسابات محدده ودقيقه الا ان من الممكن ان
يمتلت الوضع
في حاله تصاعده في وجه اسرائيل بطريقه غير
مرغوب فيها
ان يعني
التحسب هناك تحسب وتخوف ان تمتد المخاطر
ليس في القطاع فقط بل تمتد الى الضفه
الغربيه واذا استمرت ان تمتد الى سوريا
ولبنان
الحاجه الثالثه ان اهداف اسرائيل من
العمليه تحققت اذا وبداوا في رصد هذه
الاهداف انا ممكن اقول لك
هم في تقديرهم من العمليه يعني حققت مكاسب
كبيره بالنسبه لاسرائيل
احنا هنتكلم عليها ده تقديرهم وبدون مشاعر
يعني من غير ما حد يزعل يعني انه اغتيال
قيادات ميدانيه من الصف الاول لها وزنها
دفعه واحده ولم يحل محلهم الا قيادات
صاعده
فده مكسب كبير لاسرائيل اه ان تم ضرب
مقرات ومنشات ومخازن واماكن
الحركه
بمكسب كبير
ان تم مراجعه واختبار منظومه الدفاع
الاسرائيلي بشكلها الجديد بعد تغطيه
الثغره المتوسطه المدى فيها ده بيعتبر
بالنسبه لهم الحياه بالذات بعد ما اثبتت
هذه المنظومه كفاءه ده بيعتبر ايضا من ضمن
الاهداف المحققه من مثل هذه الجوله يعني
انه
تكريس سياسه الفصل بين حماس
الجهاد نجحت فيها وبالتالي تم رصد يعني
اداء المنظمات
المتعلقه الاخرى فيما يتعلق بهذه المواجهه
تم رصد يعني شبكه اتصالات حركه الجهات
بالخارج ويعني وبالذات بايران كيف تصرفت
ايران في مثل هذا الموقف
[موسيقى]
وبالمناسبه يعني لم يكن هناك جسر جوي بين
ايران والحركه ايران ما لحقتش موضوع ابتدى
الثلاثه خالص الجمعه والسبت يعني
تم تقييم
يعني مدى واهداف صناعه صواريخ الجهاد في
اخر مواجهه في القطاع تم تحليل مكونات
الصواريخ المختلفه اللي تم اطلاقها
وبالتالي
بالهندسه العكسيه هيعرفوا يوصلوا لاي حاجه
ولو انها ليست صواريخ معقده حتى الان يعني
في تقديرهم ان الحركه حركه الجهاد وهي
حركه مقاومه لم تستطع استهداف لقيادات
عسكريه اسرائيليه ولا قصر الجنود ولا
تعطيل مطارات وموانئ ولا حاجه ملموسه
وانما تم استهدافه محدود للغايه
وله دلالات رمزيه اكثر منه فاعليه
ان قدرات الحركه في الاخر وصلوا هذا
التقييم ان قدرات الحركه اقل بكثير ولا
تقارن بشيء مع قدرات حركه حماس
اذا مثل هذا التحليل جمعه
وصلوا التحليل الاسرائيلي التحليل كل
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه مشترك تم
رفعه فبدا الجناح الخاص بالتهدئه ومعامله
والعمل على الوصول للاتفاق يعمل فانحاز
نتنياهو او اجبر نتنياهو على الانحياز
لهذا
لكن في نفس الوقت كان يعني لو تشوف
البيان اللي صادر عن وقف اطلاق النار بين
الحركه والخلافه وحركه واسرائيل ببساطه
مصريه على فكره مصر اشتغلت جامد قوي كانت
لها جهود مضنيه الحقيقه يعني سامح شكري في
الاول وزير الخارجيه قال مازلنا جهود
مضنيه وحتى الان لم تؤتي ثمارها ساعه ما
كنا وصلنا لعشر ساعات وان حصل ضرب الصاروخ
اللي نزل موت واحده ديت في عسقلان تل ابي
فقالوا لا
اه اسرائيل قال له لا لانه عاوز عاوز يكمل
فبيجد ذريعه
انما كان ساعتها مثلا نائب رئيس الدائره
السياسيه نزل وقابل الوزير عباس كامل عدد
من خوره
رئيس المخابرات نصعد من القيادات في قياده
المخابراتيه رفيعه المستوى المتوليه الشان
الفلسطيني توجهت الى بيروت للقاء امين عام
الحركه المتواجد في بيروت لان هو
توجهت الى بيروت للقاء امين عام حركه
الجهاد المتواجد في بيروت كما هو اللي في
ايده ايضا ان هو يقول قرار
وقف القتال من عدمه ان كان في وفد اخر طلع
على اسرائيل ان كانت المطالب
حركه الجهاد كانت نمره واحد التزام
اسرائيلي محدد وكامل بتتعهد في بعدم
اغتيال او تصفيه قيادات الحركه وهذا
الالتزام تكون مصر مسؤوله عن ضمانه
والنمره 2 هو تسليم جثه خضر عدنان القيادي
خضر عدنان هذولا كان المطلبين الرئيسيين
بالاضافه المطالب اخرى اسرائيل بدات تتشدد
لانها كانت تحاول من تحسين موقفها التفاوض
فهي بالفعل حسنت من موقفها التفاؤل ولم
تستجب
والحركه للاسف شديد كان لم يكن قصادها
امامها غير انها تدخل في وقف الاطلاق
النار لانه اوريدي خسايرها كبيره داخل
القطاع
البيان لما صدر لم يذكر
اغتيال
القيادات الحركه ولكن قال تمتنع عن
اسرائيل عن استهداف الافراد
المدنيين
في في قطاع غزه لم يتم ذكر تسليم جثمان
القيادي اللي توفر السجون الاسرائيليه ولو
ان في اعتقادي الشخصي طبقا يعني المعلومات
ان مصر تعهدت انها حتجيب مثلها لا يهم
اسرائيل في شيء اكثر من انه كان هي عاوزه
تسترد جسامين جنودها عند حماس ولكن حماس
خارج الموضوع
بس
هذا هو الموقف
انا عندي سؤال اخير لان احنا يعني
على الجمهور كده عندي سؤال اخير هو موقف
حماس ابن القصه هي بتعتبر انما يجري بين
الجهاد واسرائيل امر يخصهما
طالما ان الجهاد لم تستاذن حماس في مثل
هذا الموضوع اذا جهاز حركه الجهاد لابد ان
تتحمل مسؤولياتها ان حركه حماس وده
التقدير الاسرائيلي ان حركه حماس حركه
سياسيه عقلانيه واقعيه
بتلتزم باي وقف اطلاق نار او باي تعهدات
هي بتتعهد بها ولا تنقدها وانها احيانا
طبقا للتقييم الاسرائيلي انها حركه نفعيه
وانها تحصل على مزايا في مقابل مواقف
تفوضيه باجابه سريعه ما موقف السلطه
الفلسطينيه لا حول ولا قوه السلطه
الفلسطينيه تقدمت بشكر وافر للجهود
المصريه اللي كانت طبعا كانت متضامنه
ولكن ليس في يدها شيء حاليا موقف موقف
ايران ايه ايران كان موقفها غير واضح وان
لم يكن جدي او او ايجابي يعني ما كانش فيه
خطوات فعاله لكن في ايديا حاجه ممكن
تعملها يعني ما بيبقى في ايديها بالنسبه
لحزب الله مثلا لكن دي حركه اقل اهميه
بالنسبه لايران من حزب الله مع السفير انا
انا شاكر جدا ليك حضرتك اجبت على الاسئله
كثيره وفي نقاط اخرى تستحق طرحها لكنها
مول ان احنا نسمعها من خلال قناتك اللي
انت سوف تطلقها خلال ايام والقناه في حدود
معلوماتها زي ما انت قلت لي قبل التسجيل
هيبقى اسمها اسرائيل الصندوق الاسود
اسرائيل الصندوق الاسود وانا هتناول فيها
الحقيقه المجتمع الاسرائيلي من الداخل حتى
تناول المؤسسات العسكريه المخابراتيه
العمليات الخاصه بالموساد عمليات التجنيد
عمليات التنصت عمليات التصفيه الجسديه
عمليات الاختطاف شكرا جزيلا معالي السفير
كثر الف خيرك اشكرك واشكر جمهورك الكريم
وقناتك على الاستضافه ربنا يخليك ويسعدك
شكرا جزيلا على السفير وشكرا جزيلا
لحضرتكم